Creepy woody and this place is great for kids.
Wait...
It's episode 31 of IMG!
Parents are
awesome, except when they play favorites.
And here's Bert
in real life. There won't be any cats in this
episode, but there will be zombie
jean shorts rigor mortis girls and
plenty of dogs.
"Ugh, are we gonna go yet?"
"Hi-five!" "Ice,
hahaha, it makes me happy."
Oh and the thing I said about no cats -
- not true. Here is one you can buy at a grocery
store. But let's move on to insects,
dead ones. Magnus Muhr symbols dead
flies into poses,
draws limbs and props and takes a
picture. Hey, this one got to me to moth.
Some people earn their swag and some
people
are born with it.
Got a problem, player? Best
party ever. You gotta peel 'em all.
Well, seriously, let's peel 'em
and enjoy some banana art.
Not enough?
Well, reddit provided the ultimate. Reddit
also showed off this colorized photo of
Abraham Lincoln from the White House Museum.
He looks kinda weird, right?
Well experts say that his odd face
may have been caused
by multiple endocrine neoplasia type 2b.
Let's get chart-y. This is the famous Venn diagram showing the relationships
between mythical creatures.
But more importantly, nerdy weddings.
They're gory, lightsaber-y and super sweet...
crotch.
Phil Noto is an artist whose work I love.
Superhero tensions.
Jon Hamm
as Superman and battleship shoes.
Whenever I see shoes like that I'm like,
hey,
nice shoes, and then girls were all like
thanks, they're vans; awesome!
MoIllusions.com
delivered my
favorite - ambigram.
This word spells black one-way
and upside down it spells white. Now, I've shown you rotating snakes before - the image
that moves when you look at it.
I mean, seriously, look around the image, pause the video,
it'll creep you out. But this one's new to
me and it's really neat. Look at the
different letters
and as you look around it will seem to
grow and move. But now, a bunch of punching
bags hung all over the place,
except from one angle they're Muhammad Ali.
Wilson Hennessy
blows my mind.
A cigarette that almost disappears,
a painted paint can that almost disappears and
how is this possible?
Finally,
Sarah Dayo has been creating what
look like half-open
doorways with an oddly shaped mirror.
GIF break.
Toast like a boss.
Still want more? Well, you're in luck. We
almost have five thousand pictures submitted
by people like you
on Facebook.com/VsauceGaming, including
Muhammad's nervous banana and Kelly's screenshot from
Vsauce Leanback. Wow, be careful,
don't look directly into his eyes.
Oh, and remember creepy Woody? Well to find out where that's from and how you
can get your own,
check out today's new episode of LÜT right
here. It's just like this show, except you
can buy everything I mention.
And hey, as always,
thanks for watching.